which nfl player would you want to be
your
bodyguard i guess either physically or
verbally if need be peter king gets the
first pick then sims then me and i will
be sure to crap on chris's pick and then
he won't be able to react to that until
after peter picks and it will frustrate
chris so i love these three-man drafts
peter you're up
i'm taking richie incognito because
i mean i think i join i join all of
america in saying i'm actually afraid of
richie incognito
and so
i if i'm the quarterback or if i'm
anything on the oakland raiders
i am looking over at ritchie incognito
and thinking thank god we got a lial
alzado you know a latter day lyle alzado
on this team who is going to be there
at the front of every line if anybody
touches my quarterback and if i'm derek
carr i say give me five incognitos
wow i just can't belie i didn't think
you would i didn't think you were smart
enough to pick him really i didn't i
can't believe it wow i thought i was
gonna need a bodyguard
i thought i was going to have the crown
jewel with that first pick right there i
mean i'm with you i hear you he's a
psycho i mean didn't he beat the crap
out of his own ferrari or lamborghini
once plus he he worked for the cia
doesn't he didn't he tell the guy in the
gym that they'll throw weights at you so
that was a very good pick yeah and oddly
enough
i'm staying on the same offensive line
because my first pick would be trent
brown now that you took richie on
incognito i'm going with trent brown
he's the largest human in the nfl there
will never be anybody to attack me or do
anything if he's my bodyguard they're
not even going to say a word they're
just going to look at him and go is that
a cloud oh no that's trent brown at six
eight three hundred and eighty pounds i
mean he is the largest human being in
football he could like
beat the crap out of all three of us
with one arm and then take out a whole
nother flock of people with other arms
so
trent brown in my first pick
um
yes i agree with both of you but it's
deja vu all over again because
uh it's last wednesday it's daniel
hunter i want danielle hunter to be my
bodyguard just like we went through this
conversation last week about danielle
hunter being overlooked and and chris
went into the whole danielle thing hey
look daniel is the name get it right and
if somebody who's given me a hard time
accidentally says to neil hunter's name
incorrectly i'm off the hook it's
between daniel hunter and whoever was
messing with me so for that reason on
top of the fact that the man is a giant
that the man is a badass that the man
will take care of you if he needs to i
want to neil hunter in my corner
you know i'm going to take the smallest
guy of the nine that we picked today and
i'll explain why i'm taking tyron
matthew
as my second pick
because
he walked into the team
that ended up winning the super bowl he
walked into this team and immediately he
became the big man on campus
and i remember i it might have been
september october whatever
but
talking to andy reid he said to me one
day he goes
you cannot believe tyron matthew
and the hold that he's gotten on the
defensive players on this team and then
covering them a lot in the postseason i
mean guys patrick mahomes is looking up
to tyron matthew and so to me
that's the kind of guy i want and did
you see him
during the super bowl when things
weren't going great tyron matthew was
pulling like a tom brady on the
sidelines
and you could see all these guys on the
sidelines of the kansas city chiefs are
okay all right you know so to me i don't
think it has to be somebody who weighs
360 pounds i don't think it has to be a
guy who you know can physically
beat you up
tyron matthew is going to be the kind of
street fighter who not only physically
is tough but mentally is really a tough
human being
that's that's a good one nice creative
pick right you're right i wouldn't want
to mess with him you're right he's going
to be able to street fight he can use
his brains he's tough as hell who knows
a guy like him he might know like
jiu-jitsu too and put you in some crazy
headlock you never know so uh i i like
that pick that's a that was a good one
i'm gonna go with khalil mack the the
chicago bears that's my next guy i mean
you guys again i'm not i like what peter
said it's not about the biggest guy
always i do like big people and khalil
mack is big compared to the average
human being but it's the way he's built
and i know you guys have seen him in
person before i mean he is just the
ultimate powerhouse let alone he could
take on the trent browns of the world
and the other big offensive lineman with
like one arm and just throw them around
and do crazy crap like that but you want
to talk about legs and butt man khalil
mack he'll throw you off of him his arms
his neck his shoulders i mean pound for
pound the what i see on the field like
on a weekly basis he looks like he's one
of the strongest guys in football and
then when you see him in person i think
you have a similar thought too i mean
he's one of those guys that you know i
say this a lot like i i don't think you
could stick a knife on them you stuck a
knife in them i think the knife would
bend before it would actually like
penetrate muscle and khalil mac
you know this is amazing to me because
i've got some creative options that we
could really have some fun with and
maybe i'll save some of them for that
little after we finish the draft names
we throw out there how in the hell have
none of us mentioned aaron donald yet
for crying out loud speaking of knives a
guy who trains with knives they may not
be real but it's a great effect
no one is going to mess with you if
aaron donald has your back are you
kidding me of all the guys in the nfl i
mean some of these other guys they may
be wired a little bit too tightly and
they may be willing to go out and do
some things that the normal person won't
do but aaron donald i mean if
something's going down i want aaron
donald to be the one to protect me
because uh he will and and there is
nobody who is going to get by him there
is nobody that's going to stop him there
is nobody who's going to derail him and
there's nobody's going to hurt me when
aaron donald is around i'm amazed he's
lasted this long give me aaron donald
please
you know your third pick i had to pick i
had to pick between brothers
okay
and i had to pick between mike pouncy
and uh marquis pouncey and it was a
tough call and i'm gonna take marquis
pouncey
because when i look at the head coach of
that team and i look at mike tomlin who
is as tough a guy who is rome who roams
in nfl sidelines
and his ambassador on the field right
now his guy who he sends out there to
make sure that there's going to be order
on the field that's marquis pouncey
and i have a feeling that if there were
no striped shirts
on the field last year that there's a
good chance that marquis pouncey
would have done something to miles
garrett
uh you know would have taken the
proverbial law into his own hands
and uh it would not have been pretty
but again i would have take i i would
have taken mike pouncey either because
he is one of those
alpha dog kind of guys who is going to
make sure at the end of every game
you know
that you have been if not physically
dominated you have had a take no
prisoners game with mike pouncey
yeah i hear that you're right and you
know i'm not to lie i've
i kind of thought about taking miles
garrett because of that similar
situation there right i mean at least
we've seen that but i'm not going to do
that because i don't like what he did
that day so i'm not going to give it any
credit even though i just gave it a
little credit um i'm going with quentin
nelson
okay quentin nelson i mean you guys like
you watch a guy he's just a huge human
block he's like a cinder block with arms
and legs and again then he's got like a
smaller cinder block for a head i mean
that's really what he is he'd be one of
those guys and i've been around quentin
nelson a lot of times first of all he's
like that scary silent type right and
that to me scares the hell out of me and
scares guys in the locker room too
because you never know he's got like the
scary silent type with a little twinkle
in his eye and you're like i'm not
messing with that guy in the locker room
i feel like if i play with him he's
going to get enjoyment out of like
punishing me into the ground and
torturing me and like release some evil
type laugh
so that's where i love quentin nelson
let alone he's the best most physical
offensive lineman in the game right now
and he can block guys like aaron donald
one on one and do those things so
quentin nelson is a guy that will look
the part and i think if it goes down he
will act the part too
yeah you know what i'm surprised he
lasted as long as he did he was on my
list peter i'm surprised you didn't make
some sort of a comment about somebody
giving marquis pouncey an envelope in
your comments earlier in the in the
draft
that's a different point all together um
here's here's my last one and i've gone
back and forth with two or three of them
but
to the extent that we set this up by
playing kyle's use check and his
somewhat passionate defense of his
quarterback i'm reminded of the most
passionate and colorful defense that we
saw and heard last year of a quarterback
and it was before lamar jackson truly
landed on the mvp radar screen although
he eventually would have the mark ingram
pitch for lamar jackson that thing's
great i just watch that from time to
time just because it makes me smile and
it makes me laugh but the intensity of a
mark ingram and yeah he's not the big
imposing presence but nobody's going to
mess with you if mark bingram is is
around he's he he will intervene and he
will state your case and he will state
your case in a very compelling way when
he has to so i'll take ravens running
back mark ingram as my pick the last
pick in the draft all right who else is
there who else did you have in the tank
peter that didn't make it onto the list
you know the guy who i really wanted to
use
because you know what we should have
done we should have each been able to
pick one historic figure
one guy go ahead the course of nfl
history that we would have liked okay
and i'm gonna take warren sapp because
he is
you know in previous days and times
he is what in my opinion right now
richie incognito is on the offensive
side of the ball you know you don't want
to mess with warren sapp and i just
always felt like when he was on the
field if he did anything
every one of the 10 guys on his team
whether they really felt like he was
doing the right thing or not they were
going to be right behind him in the
brawl
yeah
as the person who is the beneficiary of
the services of the bodyguard you always
want to be 100 certain the bodyguard's
not going to turn on you with warren
sapp i wouldn't be 100 certain that he's
not going to turn on me at some point so
i wouldn't want warren sapp chris
uh i i think i think he'd be loyal to
you in my experience i i think he would
be i do uh so i won't say that i don't
think he'd turn on you he might you know
have a few colorful words for you as
your bodyguard every now and then and
tell you where you're stupid or wrong
but i think when it got down to it he'd
stick up for you i'm gonna go to one of
my dad's old teammates i mean i i gotta
pick lawrence taylor i mean come on you
guys have seen the nfl films i mean
lawrence taylor's a psycho and then was
a psycho on the field and also
you know well-publicized psycho off the
field so i just don't feel like he'd
ever be scared of any situation and
again of course with the athletic
prowess and power and being one of the
most explosive people we've ever seen in
the history of the league uh you know i
know i'm a little biased here but lt
would certainly be my bodyguard if you
could pick an all-time great
yeah you know i think we mentioned him
earlier this week i just got a thing
from mike ditka i'd want mike ditka to
have my back mike ditka in his prime uh
with the cigar you know because it's not
just
what what the guy could do physically
99.9 of the time he's just there as a
deterrent i mean how more intimidating
can you be than ditka with sunglasses
and a big cigar you know in a jacket
standing next to you nobody's going to
mess with you he's not going to have to
do any bodyguarding if he's just there
it's that presence and uh give me mike
ditka in that regard i thought about cam
newton from that same
here because
cam newton is a giant no one
cam newton's never gonna have to get his
hands dirty if he's your bodyguard cause
nobody is going to mess with you when
they see superman standing to your side
guys
i i i hear that that's
trent brown
bond miller good one i'm disappointed
you didn't pick me florio i mean every
time we go to a look at that i mean i'm
always i'm always carrying you look at
that
uh man you already are kind of hey hey
let me tell you let me tell you this was
funny a quick story and then we got to
take a break
after the super bowl when the chiefs won
and you remember all the stuff with the
the the comments that i said about
patrick holmes and how they should
defend him and how that all got twisted
my son was with me and my son is very
physically imposing and he was damn sure
nobody was going to say or do anything
to his dad on the way out of hard rock
stadium in miami and it made me proud
but he was very he was very intense and
he was looking everywhere is there's
going to be some chiefs fan that comes
up and tries to say something or take a
shot so i got to throw my son on there
as well
and he had that
he had he was wearing the rob lowe
nfl shield hat remember when rob lowe
wore that at the nfc championship game
and everybody got a big kick out of it
he had that hat on which made it even
more imposing so all right let's take a
break
in san francisco for richard sherman he
was looking for you i was ready just in
case
oh really i didn't know about that you
did yeah it's true on the field before
the game right i had my head on a swivel
god i've wiped that out of my memory
that was everything before the pandemic
i've forgotten about we got more pft
live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports